[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello my name is kelsey and welcome to
our second annual annapurna interactive
showcase we had the best time sharing
all of our latest games and partnerships
with you last summer so this year we're
back again to show you what we have in
store for 2022 and beyond
today we'll have about 25 minutes of new
reveals closer looks at games you've
seen before and spotlights on a few
developers we are thrilled to be working
with we want to thank our fans and
partners all over the world for making
this showcase possible let's get started
[Music]
hi i'm ikanayaka and i'm meghna jayanth
welcome to the joyful and surreal world
of thirsty suitors
thirsty suitors is an action-adventure
rpg about fighting your exes
disappointing your parents and finding
yourself
this is jala she's back in her hometown
of timber hills after a brutal breakup
and has to face everything she left
behind her immigrant parents tatted
expectations claustrophobic small town
gossip did you love me jolla and the
string of messily broken hearts she left
in her wake the player shapes jala's
story through narrative choices woven
through skating cooking with her parents
and fantastical turn-based combat with
their thirsty ex-suitors each suitor
battle is a battle with past as jalas
confronted with their ex's perspective
of a narrative she thought she knew
let's look at how combat and narrative
work together during the battle with
jala's third grade boyfriend sergio
jealous base attack does damage and
builds up her willpower taunts reveal
your opponent's weaknesses by putting
them in a mood
my mom says i'm irresistible and my mom
is always right
so let's hit him with a thirsty torch
[Music]
now sergio is in a thirsty mood his
attacks do less damage and have a chance
to backfire
when he's in this mood jala's thirst
skill does way more damage
in between their attacks and deflections
the player shapes jala's personality and
backstory through choices which build up
her persona
just when jala thinks she's getting
through to sergio he pulls her into his
inner world a psychic landscape where
he's the man he imagines himself to be
in reality what the hell i can't make a
dent sergio's ego makes him invulnerable
to attack
what's a girl to do like most south
asian men all it takes to destroy
sergio's ego is a single word from his
mom jala summons the next best thing to
help her win this psycho drama battle
her mom
jala hits sergiot with a rage taunt
which brings all of sergio's very
resentments to the surface once this
weakness is exposed we hit him with a
rage skill
the battle ends not with a defeat but a
reconciliation they've worked through
their issues during the battle and can
now start again i'm sorry i came on so
strong
as friends or maybe even something more
when jala needs to clear her head she
heads out to the abandoned theme park
just outside of town to go skating these
days it's run by the bear mascot soundy
and his creepy cult of skater point kids
our approach to skating is to make it
accessible not too punishing but also
add enough depth for folks that really
want to get into it the basics are to
keep the combo meter going up for high
score
[Music]
extend the combos on rails wall runs
manuals quick turns and end on a combo
finisher for a big score
these are just some of the stories and
mechanics packed into thirsty suitors
we have so much more to share with our
players we can't wait for you to join
jala as she confronts her mistakes makes
up with her exes reconciles her cultural
differences
and becomes the person she was meant to
be
thirsty suitors is coming to steam
playstation switch and launching into
game pass
experience the game for yourself with a
thirsty suitors steam demo out now
it's hard not to think about how time
has changed the memory of you
how it will continue to change to shift
until i'm left with a version i've
created in my head
i'm packing things up
clearing out your stuff
sorting through memories that twist and
turn
depending on the way you look at them
it's hard not to drift into the past
[Music]
to remember everything all at once
[Music]
back when you were still here
[Music]
me
[Music]
our studio is called cardboard computer
and it's just it's just three of us
so my name is jake elliott i'm the
writer
in this studio i guess in the team and
and i asked to do a lot of programming
tomas and i kind of share programming
it's like art writing
sound
i was playing music and some touring and
making records i guess i caught jake in
his last year we were at the school
there institute of chicago all three of
us were living in chicago around 2010 i
think tomas and i wanted to make a video
game and we had a few other ideas
before we settled on kentucky rat zero
we brought ben on for the second
act i think and that was in
the spring of that same year because we
were
somehow managed to release
the second act in a few months
[Music]
it would be friday night and we'd be
like okay i bet if we worked all night
tonight i bet we could publish this game
tomorrow morning and we were like okay
we would work all night and it wouldn't
be quite done we'd be like okay but i
bet we could do sunday i bet if we kept
going you know and um didn't end up
being possible so
we had to adjust our expectations a
little bit seven years it's like another
three years before that learned a lot
about our own processes and i think
that's still kind of
carrying over into the new project
right after kersey came out i think we
moved directly into this new game
but the idea has been kicking around for
years maybe as old as kerosene
we're working on a new project it's the
first project we're really seriously
focusing on performance as like kind of
a core part of the piece krz it's like
very still there's not a lot of
animation everything's sort of like
these slow idle tableaus so we're sort
of doing a lot of r d with making it
more lively this is a version of like
fully animated characters that we can do
as a three-person team basically
this workflow is already just so
exciting
this time we have a lot more knowledge
going into it the beginning of kentucky
route zero was a more staggered sort of
development and now we've known each
other for so long and we're comfortable
with each other and i think that informs
making the new work in a way that feels
substantial and exciting the new game
it's it's about a different tempo it's
faster and and and hopefully funnier and
there's comedy in krz
but it's a tragedy but it's a tragedy
it's not a tragic comedy though no it's
just a tragedy yeah just a tragedy
i thought i was done with this life
but i suppose that's not my privilege to
possess
some skill sets are a curse
maybe someday i'll find the peace in
that
sadly
today is not that day
[Music]
[Music]
i hope tomorrow is different
a link to the past was the reason i got
into making video games
it was from my dad he passed away and
that was one of the last things that he
left
i came back to it when i was in my early
teens
it was just a really sentimental and
emotional experience
and when i beat it i was like oh man
i really want to make an experience like
this for someone else
so i started to make my own game
and i would stream the whole process
and i had a pretty active community on
twitch and chris was one of the first
people
i was thinking how am i gonna make this
game alone
then one day he started typing in my
chat
he said do you have a mic
that's how it all got started
[Music]
hey i'm chris hoffman i'm the programmer
at a company that fabian and i started
called yarn owl i work in austin
and fabian works in atlanta we've
been working full time on the project
together for a little over a year and
never met
hey hey how's it going
this is fabian first time i'm meeting
alma she's very excited about this very
excited like i've talked to alma as much
as i've talked to chris
and then you know you can hold it again
to charge again and cool again to charge
again yeah that's awesome
after work we both come home and start
working on the game then at the end of
2020 i shot him a message one day and i
said hey are we really going to make
this game he said yeah i quit my job
that day and then in 2021
we started yarn out i was like man he is
fully on board so from that point i just
figured that he would be the best person
to work with
he does everything code and i do
everything art
we'll just hop in a meeting for like a
good hour but then it ends up being like
three hours four hours because we get
excited just talking about different
ideas
it was definitely emotional now all of
this is happening and all of this is
real if i didn't get a link to the past
from my dad or even wind waker later
from my mom just getting those games as
a kid is what motivates me now
to want to make an experience just like
that
hey it's been a little while and i just
wanted to reassure everyone that no you
did not collectively hallucinate our
announcement of outer wilds for the
nintendo switch
that's possible we are a bit over
optimistic on the time frame
at this point it's possible we just
fundamentally misunderstand the
gregorian calendar but it's still
happening and we're working hard to
bring a great version of outer wilds to
the switch
thank you for your patience we'll have
new info for you as soon as possible
with that said we also have some good
news
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
your every move intensifies my pain
your blind ambition
all your good intentions
everything you touch turns to ash
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
for a long time i didn't even know that
i wanted to make games and i always
loved writing stories in school
and learning about the mechanics in
video games at some point i just thought
okay maybe i can combine those two
things
i'm a computer kid
i like working in these creative
programs and and those were the first
steps of kind of like expressing myself
my name is kai and i'm a writer and one
of the co-founders of third shift i'm
fabian i'm the artist and one of the
co-founders of third shift
right now we are in the west of germany
in my apartment which is at the same
time the headquarters of our little
company when we started thinking about
our project we love brainstorming
actually on
on this balcony here
and this was when the idea was born
[Music]
forever goal is a story driven road trip
adventure game where you play as alfred
an elderly man who embarks on a journey
in his trusty van
the story is inspired by a trip i took
down the pacific coast fabian and i were
always interested in the diverse
landscapes in north america and that's
where a lot of the inspiration came from
when kai
was about to go on this road trip he
asked me to
lend him my camera after he came back he
shared that book with me like as a thank
you
this was actually taken in the middle of
nowhere you can drive for hours on end
and there's just no one
and this was just crazy to see yeah we
have a scene
just like this in the game
alfred was the first thing we had
character model of airflow didn't always
look like this
this is what alfred used to look like we
started redesigning alfred and making a
little bit more lifelike
alfred's main purpose is to document
this trip
usually the games that stuck most with
us are story driven games
i'm just excited to see when people
actually play this thing in the future
and i hope this will be very soon
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
body up
[Music]
uh
[Music]
making games is a process
you try and guide it but you're trying
to guide like a gushing river
often people reach for
stories they've already heard we really
want to pull from our own experience as
much as possible because it feels the
most kind of real
i'm laura i'm the director at dreamfield
this is the hellfire club way back when
dreamfield started this is one of the
first places we came for like research
ireland is full of ruins and those ruins
speak to a history of violence sometimes
a history of change as well
greenfield started as a label for my own
work and then i met leah it was just
going to be a few sessions but it turned
into like a full-time week just
exploring we developed loads of ideas
and one of them uh became if found
suddenly there was a dynamic we're like
playing off each other and then as more
and more people come in kind of like
grows its own identity
i think like creativity is when you
bring like one like random idea from
here and one random idea from somewhere
else and like see how they could join or
like what they could do together
and when you have
lots of team members that just happens
it's really important to me that we have
the energy and we enjoy it we come here
so like today
instead of showing computer screens i
wanted to show like dream feel as like
all of these people coming together
the new game is set in kind of like a
fantasy version of ireland probably the
most obvious first detail is that all
the characters are cats
i think art wise we have something very
unique we have themes that i think are
very relevant these days about coming
together in the face of adversity
everything drowned will someday rise
from the d the eerie message and theme
of our game
and lots of cute cats
the goal is to
be creative together and make something
that is worthwhile well i think what's
fantastic about dreamfield is that um
whether you're working on the music or
the art or the programming you're really
invited to like bring your best to the
table everyone kind of leaves a mark on
it which is really nice
in a lot of ways i think dream feel has
become more polished as we've gone on i
think this game will feel more polished
even compared to effend but i hope that
we still bring that edge of like
exploration and adventure
into it
me
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
thank you so much for tuning in to our
second annual annapurna interactive
showcase we hope you enjoyed it and
we'll see you all again next summer
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
you